d'accord, je voudrais m'excuser sans condition et sans
réserve auprès de cette maison car
nous sommes mon comportement l'autre jour a clairement
permis à la passion et à la colère que
quelque chose que j'ai lu d'empêcher de répondre de manière
appropriée à une question
au chef de l'opposition que je vous
présente mes excuses  dans toute cette maison
dans mes électeurs je suis à peu près certain
qu'il y aura d'autres occasions
dans cette maison où je répondrai à des
questions que vous n'appréciez pas je
ne pense pas que ce sera la dernière fois
que j'aurai  se lever et répondre à une
question qui ne répond pas efficacement,
Monsieur le Président, je peux dire que
malgré ce que les gens pensent des enfants en
pantalon court, c'était ma réponse et
j'assume l'entière responsabilité et ils se sont
excusés auprès du chef de l'opposition
jusqu'à ce que mes cafés